[Musique]
stéphane mandard bonjour bonjour à tous
le directeur de madininair madininair un
organisme sous forme d'association qui
travaille à la mesure du taux de
pollution de l'air en martinique et
l'air que nous respirons et est viciée
depuis plusieurs années maintenant par
les émanations des algues sargasse alors
à madininair vous vous en préoccuper
particulièrement depuis trois ans à
travers un réseau de surveillance un
réseau dites vous premier du genre en
france
absolument c'est si on avait déjà connu
ce genre de mesure de qualité de l'air à
proximité d'algues en décomposition
ailleurs notamment en bretagne avec les
algues vertes et sous forme de quelques
études ponctuelles de ci de là c'est la
première fois effectivement qu'il y à un
réseau en continu qui permet de mesurer
les différents gaz émanant des algues en
décomposition et cela fait maintenant
trois ans que ce réseau est en est en
place même si madininair travail sur ce
sujet depuis 2011 et les premiers
échouages massifs
voilà donc on a beaucoup cherché
tâtonner sur les différentes méthodes
les différentes techniques qui
permettait de pouvoir mesurer au plus
près de la population de pouvoir mesurer
j'allais dire de la manière la plus con
tinue possible et on a plus après un
certain nombre d'années de travail
mettre en place ce réseau qui fonctionne
maintenant depuis trois ans et qui
permet de délivrer vraiment des
informations tout au long de la journée
chaque heure pour savoir un petit peu
l'état des lieux d'un certain nombre de
sites qui ont été choisis alors
précisément comment fonctionne ce réseau
comment est il disposé
alors il ya 21 capteurs en tout c'est ça
je crois 14 fixe et 7 mobile absolument
4,14 fixe qui donne donc des données
toute la journée une
il ce réseau sera augmentée d'un certain
nombre de point d'ailleurs d'ici peu et
puis il ya un certain nombre de moyens
mobiles également qui permette soin
d'ajouter des points soit d'aller plus
de spécifiquement dans un quartier
précisément pour pouvoir évaluer par
exemple la quantité d'une population qui
seraient touchés par des émanations plus
importante
donc cela fonctionne tout simplement
avec des capteurs qui sont implantés sur
des sites stratégiques alors quand je
dis ce site stratégique sont des sites
qui ont été choisis bien entendu par l'
agence régionale de santé un qui fait un
travail important sur le sujet l'aer est
choisi les points en fonction des
populations sensibles et notamment
choisi des points à proximité d'une
quantité de population assez importante
sur des endroits où potentiellement il
ya des gens sensibles c'est on a un
certain nombre de points à proximité
valence et orange et orales au littoral
c'est à dire que l'idée n'est pas du
tout d'aller sur le tas d'algues pour
mesurer les différentes émanations
direct du tas d'algues il vraiment de se
mettre à mi chemin entre le dépôt des
algues et les habitations de façon à ce
que a vraiment à ce que cela représente
la la ce que là les gens respirent au
quotidien
voilà donc et après les citrons choisi
vraiment par rapport à la population
sensible du coût cesser ces points une
fois qu'ils sont posés mesure en continu
et on a en fait c'est par panneaux
solaires donc ça nous permet de nous
mettre où on veut on va dire et puis de
pouvoir recevoir sur notre poste central
dans les locaux de madininair les
signaux en continu des différentes
concentrations respirer et mesurée alors
les objectifs finalement de ces mesures
quels sont ils alors les objectifs
vraiment il ya un premier objectif qui
est vraiment très sanitaire puisque le
haut conseil de santé publique a donné
un certain nombre de valeurs seuils liés
à la santé qui sont des valeurs
journalières donc il était vraiment
important de pouvoir faire ces mesures
en continu et non pas quelques minutes
par ci par là sur des canadiens ce qui
est important pour les pour les
travailleurs qui ramasse par exemple
mais pour la population qui réside
on est vraiment sûr sur des quantités
journalières vraiment des concentrations
journalières et il fallait donc un
réseau pérenne là dessus donc l'idée est
vraiment de pouvoir faire cette
comparaison entre ce qu'on
mesurées et ces seuils journalier
sanitaires la deuxième opération qui est
peut-être la plus importante aussi c'est
de permettre aux décideurs de pouvoir
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent
lorsque les taux augmentent et donc on a
un certain nombre de systèmes d' alerte
pour nous un certain nombre de seuils
d'alerté qui nous permette va partir de
surveillance et d' alerte voilà
exactement un don c'est vraiment
attendre exactement exactement le ce
réseau d' alerte va nous permettre de
dire aux décideurs et aux comités qui se
met en place dans ce genre de cas à la
préfecture et c'est de prendre les
décisions attention c'est entendre
montré de monter à cet endroit là donc
il est nécessaire soin de ramasser en
urgence un puisqu'on sait que l'aller
les la toxicité en tout cas les gaz
commencent à ses maîtres au bout de 48
heures on a 48 heures un petit peu de
délai à partir du temps où elles ne sont
pas encore en décomposition et donc on
va pouvoir leur dire où il faut vraiment
ramasser de manière la plus urgente sur
les endroits les plus sensibles et
éventuellement prendre en compte aussi
la population si le ramassage n'a pas pu
être fait ou à temps ou de manière
suffisamment importante
alors il ya des lieux en martinique qui
eût comment dirais-je ces algues
s'accumulent particulièrement on le sait
notamment du côté du nord atlantique une
partie aussi du sud atlantique vers eux
lefrançois tous à bon escient alors
est-ce que vous avez déjà observé
effectivement des concentrations
exceptionnel inhabituelle est qui et qui
ferait qu' on pourrait même pas
intervenir tout de suite compte tenu du
taux de 2 comment dirais-je das
d'hydrogène sulfuré d'ammoniac ça ce
qu'on le rappelle ce sont ces gaz là que
voilà que vous mesurez oui ce sont de
gaz en particulier l'hydrogène sulfuré
qui est finalement le seul à poser un
vrai problème puisque l'ammoniac il ya
eu pas mal de tests qui ont été faits
des mesures en continu également puisque
c'est un gaz qu'on connaît de
décomposition sur les algues vertes csc
est un problème sur ces algues là
effectivement la manière qu'on en trouve
très très peu donc voilà on est surtout
sur le problème d'hydrogène sulfuré à
partir de cette eau là enfin voilà on a
une évaluation une évolution des taux
qui est effectivement qui a pu être
assez importante à certains moments qui
a du coup évidemment
donner le feu vert aux personnes de la
rs pour aller directement sur place voir
un peu les différentes personnes qui
habitent dans le coin et puis faire le
point pour savoir quelles étaient les
solutions le même de repli
potentiellement pour c'est pour ces
personnes qui vivent le nez dedans
lorsque si on peut dire ça comme ça
ce qui est certain c'est qu'on n'a
jamais atteint bien sûr des taux qui
était potentiellement mortelle bien
entendu ou de trés trés majeur on va
dire pour les ramasseurs alors à savoir
que les gens qui ramassent sont protégés
par un certain
nombre de systèmes et notamment des
détecteurs personnel etc qui permettent
éventuellement si le taux était vraiment
exceptionnellement important de pouvoir
également se mettre en retrait alors
cessez jamais arrivé mais l'étau par
contre pour la population et les
différentiels qu'on atteint le seuil
nous pour nous majeur il ya deux seuils
ses 1 ppm et 5 ppm à partir de 1 ppm
il ya vraiment les choses qui se mettent
en place pour pouvoir essayer de
ramasser au plus vite à partir de 5 ans
on est vraiment sur un problème de santé
un petit peu plus important alors là
aussi un autre communiqué qui qui qui
sort tous les jours donne toutes ses
interprétations des différents seuils
évidemment c'est la grèce qui a qui a
fait ses interprétations
alors justement les résultats vous vous
le dites vous les voulez communiquer
quasiment quotidiennement des résultats
de ces mesures sont consultables
disponible sur le site made in hilaire
et sur le site de la rs ou croient donc
tout ça c'est assez marrant c'est
absolument c'était vraiment ce qui avait
été voulue c'est à dire que les gens
puissent comme ils sentent ils
s'interrogent sur la qualité de l'air au
quotidien depuis maintenant 20 ans
madininair il voit l'un 17 mans tous les
jours et bien l'intérêt c'est également
de voir dans tel ou tel quartier qu'elle
est la concentration de h2s
aujourd'hui hier c'était quoi et pouvoir
un petit peu qualifié la situation
donc ces données sont complètement
transparente elle son public évidemment
sur le site internet je pense par contre
sur le site internet de madininair par
l'intermédiaire également des liens
qu'on peut avoir avec la préfecture ou
la rsl ces données sont également
communiquées aux différentes communes
donc toutes les communes concernées par
ces dépôts d'algues reçoivent tous les
jours un communiqué avec une carte et
l'interprétation sanitaire qui va avec
de façon à voir un petit peu la
situation quartier par quartier par
contre effectivement il ya moyen
d'améliorer largement cette information
est avec vous les médias d'ailleurs
qu'il faut qu'on travaille de manière
accrue maintenant que je réseau est
vraiment bien assuré bien bien
incohérent c'est de pouvoir permettre
justement aux médias locaux que ça soit
journaux que ce soit télévision et même
radio de pouvoir éventuellement utiliser
ce communiqué journaliers pour pouvoir
donner ces informations journalière de
la même façon que vous le fait tous les
jours avec avec lundi cette mode de
qualité de l'air alors lors de du
séminaire spécial sargasses qu'il y
avait eu lors de la conférence la toute
récente conférence de coopération
régionale antilles guyane c'était la
semaine dernière vous avez communiqué
vous avez présenté ce réseau de
surveillance de man in her à des voisins
de la caraïbe qui pourraient être
intéressés c'est un modèle que qui
pourrait être exporté absolument c'est
vraiment l'idée de ce séminaire organisé
par la conférence de coopération
régionale aux antilles c'était vraiment
de pouvoir partager un peu l'expérience
et les connaissances scientifiques que
chacun possède sur le système des
sargasses donc comme on le disait c'est
une première un réseau comme ça en
martinique alors nos voisins de
guadeloupe s'en sont inspiré puisque
depuis quelques jours maintenant
ce réseau est en place de la même façon
que nous et évidemment ce sera très
intéressant de pouvoir continuer à
échanger sur le sur le sujet après c'est
vrai qu'on est les on est les deux
seules villes à avoir vraiment un réseau
de surveillance qui permet d'informer la
population tels que celle-ci donc oui
cette conférence était vraiment
l'objectif c'était de pouvoir partager
ses informations
stéphane bédard on va terminer peut-être
quelques mots on a beaucoup parlé
effectivement des algues sargasse le
comment dirais-je les nuages de peu les
nuages de poussière qui se succèdent
maintenant quasiment tous les deux jours
là aussi madininair
s'y intéresse vous pouvez pas besoin de
dire quelques mots absolument alors je
rappelle que ce sont les particules dans
l'air donc les particules inférieures à
10 microns notamment et que les bandes
de sable sont un des éléments à ces
émetteurs j'allais dire sur l'eau sur
notre territoire donc ça fait 20 ans
qu'on mesure ça et qu'on a arrêté
préfectoral qui nous permet d'informer
la population lorsqu'on atteint les
différents seuils critiques qui sont qui
sont j'allais dire décidé cette
situation en d'octobre là est assez
particulière puisque dans l'est dans les
vingt dernières années on n'avait pas
forcément vu un mois d'octobre aussi
dense et surtout aussi fluctuant avec
deux jours où il n'y a pas de pic de
jours où il ya un pic de jours il n'y a
pas de pic fin c'est ca c'est assez
étonnant donc je pense que c'est aussi
avec la situation certainement
atmosphérique du moment qu'ils qui veut
ça on est on est complètement lié à
cette situation avec des taux qui sont
pas forcément très très élevé mais c'est
plutôt la récurrence des épisodes qui
est qui est plutôt embêtante
à l'heure actuelle merci stéphane
gaillard directeur de madininair d'avoir
répondu à nos questions bonne journée
bonne journée à tous merci beaucoup de
votre invitation
[Musique]